how do you get to reading more than a
million words a year in the language
you're learning is that even possible
reading is key to so many things in life
in our own language people who read well
have more socio-economic success
statistics prove this we have the case
of Elon Musk who apparently read two
books a day I think the average book has
70 80 90 000 words in it
250 300 Pages or so apparently Warren
Buffett reads 500 pages a day so those
two gentlemen read you know 30 plus
million words a year the average person
according to statistics reads in the U.S
or in typical European country 14 15
books a year a little more than one a
month this works out to a little over a
million words a year just in terms of
books but of course we read all kinds of
other stuff we read newspaper articles
online we read Twitter Facebook and so
forth so we easily read more than in a
million words a year in our own language
but how does this relate to language
learning I think reading is tremendously
powerful in language learning I always
feel that when I get to her I can read a
book away from the computer without the
help of Link or you know online
dictionaries that's a major milestone in
my learning activity so what about the
strategy of reading a million words in a
language that we're learning obviously
it's much more difficult to read in the
language we're learning the more
different the language is and especially
if the writing system is different it's
a lot more difficult so if we say that
the average person reads say a book a
month and some people read a book A Week
you know if I get to where you know this
Milestone of reading a book in in the
language that I'm learning I'm not
reading a book a week or even a book a
month in that language at least not for
a long long time so I I would say first
of all we have to make a distinction
between someone like me who is a bit of
a dilettante and I'm working on Persian
and Arabic and I throw in some Polish
versus someone who's learning English I
think for those of you out there who are
learning English who are working on
improving your English you want to be as
good as possible in English maybe you
need it for school or you need it for
work then I think the objective of
trying to read at least one book in
English a month is realistic and it
would be very beneficial to your
language skills and the same is true for
someone who is dedicated to one language
French Spanish German Chinese if you can
get yourself to where you can read a
book a month in your target language
it'll have tremendous benefits because
reading is connected to listening and
speaking we have to remember that for
most of History humans didn't and
whatever animals preceded us on the
evolutionary Gale obviously didn't read
it's not something natural to human
beings and for most of that period of
history when we had writing most people
didn't read so the fact that we are able
to read is a tremendous achievement and
all kinds of research shows that it's
connected with sound that when we
develop our ability to read we first
have to develop this what they call
phonemic awareness the connection
between the written word and the sound
and this takes time to develop
struggling readers don't hear the sounds
very well so in dealing with dyslexic
people or people who struggle to read in
their own language increasingly
educators are using teaching methods
that connect the sound to the written
word extremely important so as a
language learner we are in the situation
of a struggling reader we're not
struggling to read in our own language
with all of the consequences that has
for socioeconomic success and it's a
major problem in societies you know weak
readers have difficulty
over-represented in prisons so on and so
forth not always like I know people who
don't read well who are very successful
at what they do but largely speaking
reading is considered a shortcut to
Greater socioeconomic success if we can
improve the performance of poor readers
it'll have major impacts for those
individuals and also for society as a
whole but getting back to language
learning we want to use the same
approach in order to improve our
language learning skills so connect
audio with text as much as possible
that's why at link for every item that
we have in our libraries there is audio
and text that's why we now enable people
to grab an MP3 file somewhere or from a
YouTube video or whatever for their own
use of course there's a limit to what
they can share bring it in there's an
automatic transcription created which
then you can study as a lesson the idea
is that if you're focused on one
language you want to get to a level
where you can read a book a month and
that will really really Propel your
language skills forward because whenever
you read you are self-vocalizing we know
science tells us you know MRI of the
brain tells us that the same portion of
our brain is activated when we read as
when we speak or listen and this is true
whether the writing system is a
pictographic system like Chinese
characters or syllabary like the
Japanese writing system or a pure
alphabet like Hangul for Korean or the
Latin alphabet or the Arabic script the
brain performs the same way it's text
connects to audio
so
certainly if we're fairly good in the
language we can follow along at link I
very much encourage people to import
content of interest to link where they
also have the audio
remember that one key to reading success
is that the content be of interest so
just as I say at link we want people to
learn the language from content of
interest if you want to increase your
reading go find things that are of
interest to you and I know that kids
there are books that they like for
whatever reason they like them like
books by Roald Dahl that are very
popular with kids and now they're
fussing about the wording in those books
which is so silly because really all you
want is to encourage kids to read
nothing that is offensive to any
particular group in any particular book
is going to have a lasting impact on the
reader the most important thing is to
get the reader reading
and the same is true in language
learning read things that you enjoy and
you will improve your skills at reading
you will improve your skills if you
listen to the same content you will
improve your listening skills but there
are steps and if you look at my
statistics at link you'll see first of
all that it's much easier for me to read
in Polish than to read in Persian or
Arabic even though I have spent far more
time on Persian than uh polish so it's
not difficult for me to get up to 50 60
000 words a day of reading in Polish
when I'm really on it whereas it's much
more difficult to do that in Persian in
fact in Polish I can simply read through
the text listen to it while reading if I
want or listen to it when I'm away from
the computer come back and read it again
to pick up the words that I missed but
when I'm in Persian I prefer to go
through the lesson in sentence mode
where the audio is time stamped to the
sentence I can closely connect the words
to the audio because because I don't yet
have that phonemic awareness in Persian
because the writing system is more
obtuse to me it's I'm not so used to it
as I am to the Latin alphabet and I
should add that in Polish and I haven't
spent much time on polish but I was over
in Poland and so I imported this ebook
into link and I also was given a copy in
fact I was first given a copy of the
book in sort of book form traditional
book form then I found the ebook and I
imported it so now I can go through
reading it on linked looking up words
and then I can sit down and enjoy the
book in a traditional book format and I
think this is something well worth doing
even if you read the same thing in
different formats it all contributes
it's all part of reading can I get in
Polish to where I read a million words a
year in other words a book a month or a
little more than a book a month if I
lived in Poland if polish were the only
language I was learning I think I could
get there and I think I would make it an
objective to get there
now if we step back to Persian it's so
much more difficult for me if I lived in
Iran and if I had to get to that level I
think I would set myself the goal of
trying to read a book in Persian you
know as a goal one a month
I think I could get there part of it is
is when reading away from the computer
as I did with this other book on the
history of Krakow ignore the words you
don't know in other words get yourself
to a level using you know reading online
looking at words get yourself to a level
where you can still more or less follow
the gist of what you're reading without
having to look up words because looking
up words very much slows you down and
it's much faster to do that reading
online where you have you know a quick
reference to an online dictionary and
the other functionality that's available
an application like link to acquire
vocabulary but the goal if you are
dedicated to one language and you
genuinely want to become fluent in that
language the goal of reading a million
words a year is attainable
and I should add because not everything
you read is going to be a book so if you
read a book A Week
you don't have to get to the level of
Elon Musk or Warren Buffett and I might
add in there Bill Gates who claims I
think that he reads 50 books a year
which isn't in the 30 million words a
year but it's in more than 3 million
words a year you don't even have to get
to that level if you read a book A Week
in your target language you will
definitely surpass a million words a
year because you do reading of Articles
of newspaper articles the social media
but if you're committed to becoming you
call it C1 in your target language then
you should be able to read a book A Week
and if you can combine it with listening
so combination ebook audiobook if you
can combine the two because reading is
so intimately in our brains connected
with listening then you are going to
dramatically improve your ability to
read your familiarity with the language
all of those things in your brain are
going to be activated so I think that's
a laudable goal and an achievable goal
although I admit that with me in Persian
it's still a long way away and because
I'm not dedicated to one language I
probably won't achieve it but for those
of you who are you know determined to
really kind of Ratchet up your skill
level in a language
a million words a year is not a
difficult goal for you to achieve and
there will be many many benefits across
your language skills thank you for
listening bye for now